How do you guys feel about seasonal products here in Japan? Because you know,
every country in the world has like seasonal products and stuff,
but I feel here it's just not as heavily advertised,
like Japan, take it to the next level. Whereas half the shelf,
sometimes I feel it's like seasonal products. Every, everything is seasonal.
Everything is freemium as well.
I get it. Now I met, I remember they would talk about it in the enemies.
They were like the enemies.
You don't know the pain until your favorite item has been removed from the
Colombini. And I feel that because of that as well.
So many items that I just liked, uh, for some reason, the,
the wa the items that I specifically like would just randomly get removed from
the, yeah. I feel like I'll be like, Oh, it'll be back next week.
I'm not going to lie.
Every time I walk into a Colombini and I see something is like new,
I'm just like, Oh, I grab one of those. I don't know. Cause like.
I don't want to try it. I want to get attached.
Yeah. That's exactly. That's exactly how I feel now.
I feel like so many times living in Japan, I go to the company,
I try all this new, like, Oh,
this like new product that's only available for spring.
Cause it's like the spring special winter special products. Try it.
Absolutely love it. And then a few months later, I'm like, man,
I want it. Now you've given me a craving and you've removed the craving.
And now I'm going to have to wait all year for it to maybe come back for it to
maybe come back. Cause it might not even come back.
I hate that when they like bring out like a new, strong zero flavor.
And I'm just like, man, this is way better than the standard flavors too bad.
It's only around for two weeks and I'll never see it again once it's gone,
because it's not just like items. Sometimes there's like menu items on, on,
in like restaurants as well that are only available during certain seasons.
I mean, I feel the biggest problem with that is that the one thing in Japanese,
like especially supermarkets and restaurants that they love to do that whole
like seasonal premium is with fruits.
Oh God, we've gone out. We've ranted about food.
But like, I remember like I went to, uh, I don't remember. It was no,
it was a real host.
I went to Royal host and they were doing this like seasonal thing with grapes,
right? Like the green grapes, like the muskets.
And I tried a few of them because I like green grapes. And I was like, Oh,
this is really nice. Went back the next week. And it was gone. I'm like, hell,
this is really premium. Isn't it it's like, it was,
I swear it was only on the menu for like three days. And it's just gone. Yes.
Where they,
they take like limited time sales to like another level here because it feels
like a lot of things are just very limited.
It's a limited edition something it's limited edition products. Even, you know,
one can argue that that's like very good marketing. It is very good.
My people will look at something premium being like, well,
I guess if I can only get it now I should get it. Now.
It is,
it is kind of cool going into a place and just having stuff be new constantly.
But then there is also that fact of like, yeah,
I did really like this one thing and you took it away from me.
So I'm very upset.
Like the same thing, whenever you travel to a new like prefecture or something,
and there's every pre like we talked about before every prefecture has a
specialty and an item, you can only get in that prefecture.
Every prefecture will tell you that this is the best rice in Japan.
Every prefecture will you, it's all. So it's like definitely living in Japan.
I've tried more like I've gone out of my comfort zone with trying new products
and new suites and everything. But at the same time,
I've just found more cravings that I can't get on a normal basis anymore because
it's only available in form of certain prefect.
What was the maple cakes that we bought from the Manju that we bought from
like Hiroshima? Oh, you, it was so good.
But the problem is you can only buy IMF, hung in Hiroshima.
So it's just like cool.
Sweet person. But then I like, yeah, we bought those at one. And I was like,
I want to eat all of them.
And I stopped that. I thought the tiny, we bought a tiny bag
could have gotten the pack of 24 weeks. Then I got the pack of Asia.
You never know. Sometimes you go, you go, you try out this new thing. You like,
it's, it's all right. It's, it's made it's whatever. Right.
But sometimes you find that really amazing product and you're like, but then,
but then on the country,
isn't it amazing when you find that one regional thing that you think you're
never going to see in Tokyo and then just one random shop sells it.
it. Like I remember like, uh, in Tuskegee, for example,
they have this thing called lemon milk. Yeah. Which I love. And it's like, uh,
it was a regional specific thing for the longest time. And I was like, well,
I gotta make a trip up to, to get every time I want this.
So I would always buy it in bulk when I would come back home naturally.
But of course it doesn't last. Right.
And then the craving comes back and I get regression. But then I remember,
uh,
I walked into like a random Colombini once and they were just selling it and it
was like, it was like Eldorado. You know, it was just like,
[inaudible] bought all that and, and brought her back. I was like, all right,
put it on Google maps. This is the company that sells the, the lemon milk man.
The, the Sapporo special, um, thing. You'd be a, what is it?
What's it called again? Sapporo beer. No, no, no. It's uh,
what's the prefecture called Ocado. Yeah. Yeah. We forgot for a second.
Then Hokkaido, the support will be, it is way better when they have like the,
the Sapporo. So actual support will be, uh, yeah, so, so good.
I wanted to bring so much back, but it's heavy.
This doesn't actually make a difference though.
I genuinely think it tastes better. Yeah.
I think Sapporo in Japan tastes worse than I
remember it tasting abroad. I dunno. It's,
it's weird if maybe it's cause I have it way more often now,
but when I have support, like on tap somewhere else, I was like, Oh,
this is so much better than the beer that we, that the other day that we had.
But I think it's because you're comparing it to other bees, right?
Like I remember a Saki tasting infinitely better in Australia taste.
But now I'm more scared to go back to Australia and have the beer in Australia.
I'm like, if I think a soggy is mid now, which used to be like gone to before,
I don't want to drink a VB. Right.
Like I feel like I'm going to throw up drinking that.
I can't imagine going back and going like drinking a calling again.
Carling is like.
Water in the UK. It's one of the worst beers.
And there'll be sports bars in Japan that alike. We're partnered with.
Michelle calling in Carlsbad. I've seen that before. Uh,
odd wiser Budweiser. Yeah.
Cause I've seen like a special or special restaurants.
They sell like this tie-back singer beer. And it's like in, in Thailand,
it's like the dirtiest cheapest beer you can get,
like they don't even put it on tap. They put it in.
Like they put it in like a cat
[inaudible] in Japan. They're on a menu, like 500,
500 yen for little can of Singapore. You're wrestling.
Tyler who is going to go to Japan and be like, Oh,
we have exclusive Heineken in bottle 700 yen, please. It's like,
no, yo Heineken and Amsterdam is great.
And Amsterdam is good beer at wherever it's proved is the best. Like, you know,
uh, uh, Oh my God. I'm blanking here. The Irish one. Yeah.
Skin to skin in Ireland. Ireland is like, get us on and just hit different.
Yeah. But then I had a Guinness here on top because they were having it on tap.
So I'm like, I was curious. I was like, all right, well,
get us in Ireland is so good. I do that every time as well. I was like, Oh,
they have Guinness on tap here in Japan. Let me see you do it.
Just to get hurt because you hold out the hope, right?
You hold out the hope of me. Maybe this is the one,
maybe this is the place it's like, this pub might be the SSR pool.
It's like, miss might be the one. I mean, this is the one.
And every time I get disappointed, it's like.
No, never going to be the one. I was like, every time I see like Irish.
Pub in Tokyo, I was like, yeah, the one is that the one place that I can go is,
cause it's not even Turkey. It's worldwide for me.
Like every time I see a Guinness on tap, cause that's me on tap. Never, never,
that can't. But like it has to be on tap. Cause I'm like, it's on tap. Maybe,
maybe, maybe this is the one. Maybe, maybe they figured out the secret. And uh,
I remember waiting if,
if anyone in the world has ever tasted the Guinness outside of Ireland,
that tastes as good as in Ireland. Delusional, please, please hit me.
I need to know when we literally traveled to that place.
Why not just travel to islands gone? I'll just go to Ireland at that point.
I'm curious. I'm curious to see if there's any place outside of travel. Well,
you.
Know, this is the sad truth of it gone.
As well. Like that should does not travel. I'm okay. I'm okay with that.
Staying in Australia,
actually I had a kangaroo steak here in Japan at an Outback steakhouse of all
five places just cause I was curious and I was like, man, this does not travel.
I found that out on that day that.
He does not travel. You know, it's also bizarre. Uh, when I was in, uh,
Hokkaido, I was at a train station and there's like 11:00 AM.
There's so many people drinking beer in the station. Yeah.
Like just like everyone showing every kind of like,
you know a group you can imagine like young girls, old men, young men,
they were all just chilling in the station, just drinking a Sapporo beer. Yeah.
And I'm like, I'm like, this is weird.
It was just drinking beer at like 11:00 AM. What the? It's in the station.
They're like public waiting area.
It's like that in Okinawa as well. But instead of beer, it's our money,
which is essentially just really strong.
It's basically AKI now in vodka.
That's the only way to describe it because I forget sometimes about the public
drinking laws, which you can drink publicly, publicly here.
Because I feel like I didn't expect to see so many people were drinking in the
daytime in Japan. Like I,
I get surprised when I see an eye open because I'm like,
who the is going through? And he's like, yeah, like 12:00 AM. You'll see them.
And they'll be drinking a beverage. Yeah. I never,
I never thought that the concept of like lunchtime beer was a thing here until I
saw it for myself. I was like, wow, they're actually having one.
It's like it's for people. You don't explain it.
Cause it's always like the old people, tired people were just like, Hey,
let's just have a lunchtime crack, open a beer.
UK. It's all the old people too as well.
If you have a good of Wetherspoons at like mid day,
you'll always see the same old people Downing pints at like 12. And you're like,
it's okay. I'll be asleep by four anyways. Yeah.